when you go to the theater you're
surrendering all your screens all the
social media and you're allowing
yourself to be enveloped in an
experience that director built for you
and crafted for you
and then immerse yourself and there's no
pause button and you're all together and
so you have this incredible experience
and it can be it can be life-changing
and I think that people are hungry to
get away from the social screens
and that the easiest most simple way to
do that is to head to the cinema and
shut it all down shut everything down
and it's healthy for us right now
where we're over stimulated so it almost
sounds weird because it used to be the
stimulation spot but this is actually I
think it's a way to shut things off